hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games we
got some really good stuff for you in
this episode
lots of really good spooks lots of
scares
all right welcome to delirious press any
key controls
wise to e run sure i'm gonna need run
i don't know what i'm delirious about
probably another drinking binge
more lsd cocaine
hello okay i had to make sure that
wasn't just like a
like a head at the end of the hallway
there might still be one at the end of
the hallway but i can't see it now
anyway
oh this is ominous am i going home or am
i just
okay hello
no do i have to find mine i don't
remember i'm so drunk i i can't remember
which one's mine
oh there we are oh
i should invest in a nightlight
i don't have lights
hey how are you good to see you oh
good great that
yeah it's fine hey wow
that was spooky i i'll give you that one
that one was pretty spooky that
that was spooky i didn't like that
actually at all i didn't like it none
um weird that that's the only light in
my house
okay got a pooper that's nice
okay good mew meow doesn't
look good this is great love this place
home sweet home lovely loft
exactly where you want to be after a
hard day's work a lot of medicine
just laying around
am i supposed to do something hello
hello okay
do i go to bed what am i supposed to do
cook dinner watch some tv chill out
chillax
oh
[Music]
of right um
hey neighbor how you doing
hey good to see you you're not going
away are you
okay you just hang out there thanks man
hey
love the security in this luxury
apartment you know
really something fantastic empty empty
good
i was hoping so i was hoping so
okay you're still on the fritz that's
good to know pig pills oh good
well time to hit the old dusty trail
you're still there buddy you're still
there
okay he's gone probably for good
definitely for good actually
um yeah i don't have to worry about that
anymore ever again
good thing too yeah anyway gotta
sleep because that's what my brain tells
me to do up in here there's a list and i
i just do whatever that says
like the sims wait a minute hang on stop
stop shut up everyone shut up
where am i oh okay good
oh oh oh
oh
i don't want to run right now i'm going
to run
i'm running oh i'm running away
oh hey buddy how you doing okay all
right
i died you gotta follow the lights
yes that makes a lot of sense okay all
right
okay i gotta follow the lights i see
what's going on over here i see what's
going on i see i see what's happening i
see what's happening
oh god oh god oh god you're close you're
closer you're close you
are you close are you are you close
okay all right you know i was trying to
be careful about things
okay you're not gonna give me this time
because i know exactly where i'm going
exactly not stopping for nobody
don't stop for cops nothing and nobody
okay okay okay oh god oh god oh god
please just be a straight line please
just be a straight line please yes yes
yes yes yes
close the door okay i'll just go
damn those pills really something
okay you know what i left something at
the office
i forget
okay oh good great
good thing the lobby is this way too
and blood always a good sign
oh and i'm a chat can i have that yes i
can
can i swing it oh hey bud hey
not so tough without your machata
i'm gonna try this door before i go
charging i'm gonna
kill you i'm gonna stay
[Music]
oh
man those are some pills so the moral of
the story is
take your pills don't take your pills i
don't know if that's a good story to
have out of this but i like that that
was pretty spooky i really like the
light switch gag
i i hope that was intentional because
the eyes and the darkness thing really
spooked me that was a good start to it i
liked that a lot very short but you know
still pretty damn good i loved it great
stuff
10 out of 10. many likes many many
bubukis
oh machete i didn't notice that before
oh my goodness
also i killed like five armed guards so
i'm some kind of a badass on those pills
unless it's supposed to be like the
cycle of jason never stops
anyway all right moving on
[Music]
oh my goodness oh my goodness welcome to
hulu the fork
who do you [ __ ] who the [ __ ] who the
[ __ ]
told you that
i'm gonna plea i forget which country
this is based off but someone can
probably tell me in the comments
down below and then you guys can like up
that comment and so i can see it
nice ride my dude nice ride
all right
okay oh hey
lovely place the sweeping hills are
gorgeous
really picked a wonderful place here hi
i've made it to the bed and breakfast
house it looks
nice yeah why are you hesitant like that
man
okay okay didn't know i was going to an
airbnb here
it's beautiful the sheep come with it
use wise oh i'm now first person i think
oh
maybe oh there we go
now we're talking what happens if i just
wander off into the distance the
countryside is quite beautiful
it won't let me all right fine i'll go
inside i don't know why that's my first
instinct every time maybe because it's
actually a survival tactic
if we're in the middle of a scary
situation running away
seems to be the best option but then
again this is just a small storage house
oh okay oh i do like this though
this is cool hello
hi you like the way my hand stretches
hello hi you must be the researcher
coming to see if that build site is free
from any archaeological artifact
sure yep that's me the plane ride was
long i'm ready to rest up before i get
to work
it's nice to meet you welcome to my bed
and breakfast
come on in your room is right up the
stairs
come and meet me in the dining area
after you've settled in
okay sounds good man i'll just
just go upstairs love your house the
decor
is delightful okay
wow look at this view look look at this
view look at this view
look at that view ghoul frick
you shouldn't have so much lsd on the
road over here
oh
all right let's just go
[Music]
there we go nice i don't know what it is
but i love the animations
i i actually really like this style it's
it probably seems silly because it's so
janky but
something about it i love the jank like
this is the kind of jank that is exactly
what i was looking for
good stuff hey bud hey bud
if you know anything about the holder
folk holder folk
what's that about mean creatures that
roam
certain spots of this island they are
very territorial and will do anything
to keep people away from their land did
the builders that hired you tell you of
these creatures
no they didn't but this is a joke right
oh no no joke at all it is well known to
the faraways people that these creatures
exist
but these builders that hired you they
don't seem to be aware of the older folk
they must be foreigners well you're
right on that
the builders are from the us they want
to build a hotel here
but let's say these hulda folk are real
how would you get rid of them you can't
if you find out the build side is filled
with hull default you must stop the
build project
and you must stay away from the sight
the creatures are invisible
and they can reveal themselves at will
sometimes you can capture them on film
too
how can i tell if hulda folk lived there
keep a lookout for holes and mounds
where they live in
dirt circles on the ground indicate a
hulda folk was there digging for worms
and if there is a machine on site that
is damaged
there could have been whole default
activity
okay sure i will take your advice then
i'm only warning you there's a common
misconception about holderfolk
most people think they are not dangerous
but that isn't the case
i've had my encounters with the
creatures before and they don't like to
be bothered
they have also taken some of my sheep
i appreciate your warning and your
hospitality
now i must go lay down a bit i'm
tired this is so weird
why i mean i get the skepticism and
actually i appreciate the skepticism
like
it's about time i take a drive in the
build site so i can survey it
yeah dead of night that's a good idea
yeah definitely okay yeah let's do that
yeah let's do that but just someone goes
like
these invisible creatures that you can't
see that maybe damaged machinery maybe
they're digging holes in the ground
looking for
worms i'll catch you
don't even try to get near the hold of
oak they're going to destroy you
and your entire family your entire
family is going to go down
whereas the sheep there's the sheep yeah
they hold the [ __ ] they'll come crawling
up out of the ground if they're
finding oh i'm out of here now
beautiful day for it lovely day for it
lovely day for a hula
listening to my favorite tunes yeah
this is my best jam what a bop
just straight up slangers non-stop
oh yeah this looks safe okay it's time
to start taking some photos and
notes you got it bud let's do it clang
clang splash splash
flash flash oh yeah this looks like hold
the folk territory um
oh this
looks like it was built a long long time
ago
there's also a weird artifact on the
image
maybe the camera is dirty yeah in the
shape of a tiny gremlin
yeah definitely yeah it's just it's
dirty it's doidy yeah definitely doity
uh-huh are these these little wormholes
this is what i'm looking for
[Applause]
odd circles of dirt are there any
animals living here
maybe hulda folk baby
yeah oh yeah
there's nobody here was there supposed
to be anybody here
is it
the pooper
[Music]
okay don't look too close at that hey is
this damaged i bet it
is i bet it is
a damaged radiator is that dabbing this
needs some repairing
because dabbing there's also another
artifact on my photo
damn camera yeah yeah damn camera that
damn
camera you know what i'm saying you know
what i'm saying everybody damn camera
oh boy
all right good what is that some kind of
fertility statue
hey what's going on over here hello okay
this is normal pile of rocks could be
the doing of people from
hundreds of years ago but more than
likely had just been currently placed
here by travelers
or workers then why even mention it man
is this going to go in your business
report are people actually going to care
about this hey look a giant
butthole in the frickin mountain all
right
this is normal this is normal normal
stuff here
very normal okay this could be hold a
folk
or i'm being pranked yeah probably that
one
yeah let's go wait oh no not the lasso
they lose me no
i don't whoa you are ugly i mean i'm not
much of a looker in this game but
man you were don't throw rocks at me
you don't throw rocks at me hey
ow ow stop it
jerks i'm gonna get out of here
i'm free no am i free
oh okay uh
wait a minute was i not supposed to
hello here i go i'm down here now
oh i don't know what that was about
[Laughter]
oh
uh oh yeah i think this would never
found again
means
i loved it i really did i loved that
i loved it i loved it what a trip what a
trip
what a trip eight out of ten ten out of
eight
eight out of 18 divided by two
exceptional well did well did
i just love it for who the [ __ ]
great stuff moving on but this will live
in my memories for ages
welcome to sleepless supposedly a short
horror game about not
sleeping which is something we can all
relate to
sorry i just wanted to get you woken up
hi i'm waking up now look at my tootsies
look at my potato tootsies hold space to
close your eyes but why would i want to
do that
oh for the first time in a long time the
mouth sensitivity
is very low but i like it
closing eyes and opening eyes
oh this is going to suck in the best way
i do not like is that oh
what painting is that is that flute lady
no i don't like it
look at that neck hi
hello i don't think i oh
okay some i'd like to think someone's
just jumping up to the second floor
getting a lot of air time and then
slowly falling back down
uh yonorama
shwoopity
hello hi yes come in
come in is that the tootsie tickler hey
come in
i don't like that look at that deck
well that's japanese can you just get to
tickle in my tutsis and then move on
i'd like to get back to not sleeping
please well gonna close my eyes no need
to see that and open
well that didn't seem to fix anything
something tells me that closing my eyes
isn't actually supposed to fix it oh
no thank you i'm gonna close my eyes oh
well glad that's gone forever
i like that i like the concept of that i
i do like that there's been a few games
that have done that in the bed
and you're stuck in the bed kind of
thing but i like it it's such a cool
concept
it doesn't work for like long term i
mean a couple games have tried to do a
long term but
you know it's still it's still fun
you're trapped you can't do anything
you're just sitting alone how many
people have had that experience where
you're just in your bed and you're just
like pearl oh my god everything's
terrible you're just hallucinating
nightmares all around you there's a
nightmare there's a nightmare there's an
eye subscribe if you felt that
experience before
ring the bell if that's totally
relatable to you the like button will
trigger a jump scare as soon as you
click it
a jump scare will happen
there it is and a jump scare will happen
if you don't like the video it's a
catch-20
jump-scare you can't get away from it
it's the like button demon it's gonna
get you if you never do it
all right anyway i like that a lot
moving on
uh welcome to thy fella welcome to thy
flesh
i'm gonna start there's no instructions
oh no
my car my car is broken what happened
where am i
looks like i crashed all right well good
thing i crashed right beside i think
this is the opening to grandma
the horror game i'm pretty sure isn't
this exactly the same or was that
actually you were going to visit your
actual grandma i can't remember
either way this looks suddenly familiar
maybe because it's the premise of every
horror game i've ever played hello
please help me and don't murder me this
is literally never worked out for me
please can someone please help me no it
reads
no escape well [ __ ] i'm outta here oh
the door is gone i don't like that
that's creepy no it reads thy flesh
oh no i got a bad feeling about
this it's bad when you know that there's
a decapitated head that's just wrapped
in a paper sack
oh that's fun this is all very fun
oh this is all very fun oh i hate that
oh
i hate that yeah go away look at that
nick
a note that reads no eyes yup
a note that reads it is here what is
here
look at that nose all right
see you around buddy see you around
buddy
it is locked good maybe i shouldn't be
here
maybe i should be nowhere near here
maybe oh is that a key bam god
what happened oh it's just you
that wasn't scary also what happened to
your skin bruv
what happened to your skin you all right
okay good
time to go in the spooky basement i
would eat my way through the walls
if i was here and the door disappeared
behind me i would literally chew
through the wall it's just made of wood
it ain't gonna stop me i'm gonna get if
beavers can do it i can do it too
i don't care if it's a log cabin i'm
gonna chew my way through that bad boy
all right i know it reads it won't let
us go up well how did i get down
what does this scp-087 be it's just
flimsy tape i can chew my waist i can
jump
it's what do you mean it it won't let us
go up i came down
it won't let you go up never gonna let
me
up never gonna chew me
out never gonna run around and hurt me
oh this is great oh this feels good
this feels perfectly good very normal
i'm going up
i can't go up it won't let me go
up oh wait what yes it will wait if i
if i bow i've got to be very polite to
go up that's weird this is super weird
okay i'm just gonna keep going down oh
here we go
hello oh hi hello never look behind you
it sees
i look behind me oh no
oh no oh no do not turn around
oh god should i turn around guys leave a
like if i should turn around
okay ah
it was real it was real i dropped a key
don't turn around okay i'm in
jump scares are a bit cheap but you know
what i haven't played a game just with a
bunch of cheap jump scares in a while
it's kind of nice
sacrifice me or i have to sacrifice
like thanos good thing i brought my
pocket gamora
oh yeah this hole was made for me
oh hello
what you're gonna eat through that body
i'm gonna eat me through this wall
oh no oh oh
well grandma's getting out of his her
easy
chair
lexie and just put in a bunch of
realistic knocking sound effects at
random intervals
hi bud it's a nice dick hello how are
you
you okay you all right kind of undulate
if you're okay
like she just put in realistic knocking
sound effects and a bunch of realistic
footsteps
make it all in one ear and then the
other and then
random places and we'll never know
what's happening hello
okay yeah now put voices whispering in
in each ear at random intervals
and then like put in a sneeze but not
now later
just randomly until when people forget
about it
you okay bud you all right
hello oh that's good
someone's bumping their microphone over
there
no i don't even know what that sound is
supposed to be but it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
ah hey bud nice dick how you doing
undulate if you're okay all right good
you ever get a bad feeling about
something
that's kind of what i got about this
place
maybe i'm supposed to follow the sounds
maybe it's kind of a clue
man with all these you'll never know
what lithian added and what's actually
in the game here because
there are a lot of noises oh boy
oh boy oh i don't like big open
hey a way out certainly okay i guess
yeah
oh hey look i'm out
and the house is gone and my car is
fixed up
well time to hit the old dusty trail
drive home
yep
oh i
i'm free
[Applause]
what is it like i drive home and i close
my eyes when i drive that's what happens
i close my eyes when i drive that's why
when i got in the car
everything went black that's also why i
crashed the car in the first place
because i have a bad habit of just
absolutely driving blind
i have a hole in my pants anyway so that
was thy flesh
i kind of miss you know games that are
just like throw as many random jump
scares as you can at people
i i really do i think that there's still
a market for that
you know everything's going for like the
whole surrealist horror or like a
subversive elements but sometimes you
just want a good jump scare you know
what i mean sometimes you just want a
good scare
not always of course not always but you
know sometimes so i like that that was
pretty good
so that was three scary things
thank you so much for watching have a
happy new year and remember
keep your doors
you